[Música]
y hablamos por supuesto de revista de
prensa con migo en el estudio ya está
rosa pérez más de euros a abrimos esta
revista de prensa también con un hecho
lamentable parecido al de ayer digamos
la noticia conocida esta noche 46
personas muertas encontradas dentro de
un camión en texas en eeuu esto lo lleva
la portada del bolso y yo no buenos días
ahora exactamente y a pesar de que lo
abordaremos desde distintos ángulos y
con distintos medios hemos seleccionado
el wall street journal porque lo lleva
en portada no aclarando que al menos 46
personas fueron encontradas muertas el
lunes dentro de un tractor trailer en
san antonio el mayor número de muertes
jamás registrado en una operación de
inmigración clandestina en eeuu según
las autoridades además 16 supervivientes
fueron trasladados al hospital y de
éstos 16 destacar que 12 pues son
adultos y 4 son menores rosa también
labor de houston chronicle este
periódico del estado de texas
exactamente y nos da algunos detalles de
cómo puede ser sucedió todo y es pues un
trabajador de la construcción encontró
el camión sobre las 6 de la tarde cuando
escuchó gritos de auxilio que provenían
del interior del trailer no y ahí dentro
encontró unas 100 personas de las cuales
como decíamos 46 estaban ya fallecidas y
las otras estaban muchas abajo un estado
de golpe de calor de asfixia etcétera
porque recordemos hacia casi 40 grados
ayer en esta zona en texas por otro lado
el houston chronicle cita defensores de
los derechos humanos como la liga de
ciudadanos latinoamericanos unidos que
lo que pide es al congreso una ley
migratoria que amplíe los visados de
trabajo temporales que se puedan
conseguir desde fuera de eeuu no por un
lado para que las personas que quieran
migrar al país sí que lo van a ser
igualmente a pesar de que pues digamos
tengan que hacerlo por vías irregulares
pues no tengan que ponerse en manos de
los llamados coyotes o también pues para
que una vez dentro del país no sean
explotados laboralmente por empresas que
se aprovechan pues de la situación de
guzmán
de muchos trabajadores sin papeles por
otro lado también la ong y el houston
citada por el houston chronicle dice
desafortunadamente esta no es la primera
vez y no va a ser la última que esto
suceda mientras no tengamos vías para
que las personas migran de forma segura
a eeuu rosa y precisamente esto lo que
señalan los ángeles times the new york
times' que repasan los episodios más
mortales para personas migrantes en los
últimos años efectivamente no ambos
medios señalan que pues este episodio
donde como decíamos no se encontraron a
46 personas muertas está el hecho lejos
de ser un hecho aislado no a pesar de
que las circunstancias pues sean
distintas en cada caso hay una misma
raíz no señalan y es que pues cuando no
hay vías seguras a de entrada a un país
como decíamos las personas que quieren
emigrar refugiarse desplazarse o pues en
resumen circular por el mundo van a usar
vías más inseguras aún así sea asumiendo
riesgos incluso para la propia vida no
pues destacan pues esto que la represión
no acaba finalmente con la migración y
señalan pues episodios de masivas por
asfixia o por accidentes de tráfico en
estas rutas de emigración clandestina
señalan por ejemplo en octubre de 2019
en essex en reino unido se encontraron
26 23 personas muertas en el tráiler de
un camión también en febrero de 2017 13
personas se encontraron muertas en el
container de un barco en libia no y como
decías bien pues también un episodio que
recuerda al de este viernes en la
frontera del enclave español de melilla
no donde murieron 37 personas según la
ong caminando fronteras también algunas
de ellas por asfixia o aplastadas pues
también bajo custodia de las autoridades
a pesar de que pues de momento parece
que no va haber investigación y va a ser
difícil
esclarecer la implicación tanto de la
policía marroquí como de la española en
estas muertes y ocasiones lo que están
enterrando ni rosso efectivamente y pues
el riesgo es que finalmente estas
personas acaben siendo enterradas sin su
insonorización identificación ni
autopsia volvemos ahora con el periódico
de texas a rosa porque dirige algunas de
las afirmaciones del fallo de la corte
suprema que revocó el roe versus wade
esto cambiando de tema no al aborto
también que precisamente lo tocamos ayer
aquí en revista de prensa y como
invitada el día la sentencia que hasta
la semana pasada garantizaba el derecho
al aborto a nivel federal en eeuu
exactamente y lo hemos relacionado
porque en el caso del aborto hay
bastante consenso no para pues
establecer que que no haya digamos vías
seguras para abortar no acaba con los
abortos sino acaba con los abortos
seguros y lo que hace es que las
personas que quieran abortar pues
arriesguen incluso su propia vida entre
las verificaciones que hace este
artículo está la de que consta en el
fallo como decíamos no que de robo el
roe versus wade la semana pasada es la
siguiente no hay duda de que legalizar
el aborto reduce la población
afroestadounidense un alto y
desproporcionado porcentaje de efectos
aportados son afro y bien lo que señala
este medio citando la national black
women's reproductive justice 'agenda es
que bueno esto está relacionado pues con
el empobrecimiento de la población afro
estadounidense señala esta organización
que la carencia de acceso a la educación
sexual lo que provoca son más embarazos
no deseados y además también señala el
houston chronicle que no hay datos
fehacientes respecto digamos a los
perfiles raciales y étnicos de las
personas que abortan que lugares como
estados hay como en nueva york' no
aportan este tipo de información parece
muy rápidamente rosso que no se quede
por fuera como afecte esto las mujeres
latinas pues en latino revés encontramos
pues una opinión que va en la misma
dirección a no y es que digamos la
población más empobrecida las mujeres
más empobrecidas van a ser las que no
van a poder desplazarse a otros estados
e incluso fuera del país para tener
acceso a abortos seguros de hecho para
ti todos sin tener una activista
pro derechos reproductivos señala que de
todos los grupos demográficos las
mujeres latinas son el más empobrecido y
las que van a pues digamos asumir más
riesgos a la hora de abortar que además
un tercio de las mujeres latinas son
migrantes y el 13% de ellas no tienen
documentos por lo que es muy peligroso
para ellas más viajar dentro y fuera de
los estados rosa como siempre gracias
por la revista de prensa nos vemos
mañana miércoles con más pasamos a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado el día